FOR THE LAST 15 YEARS,
A MAN NAMED CLAYTON BIGSBY
HAS BEEN THE LEADING VOICE
OF THE WHITE-SUPREMACIST
MOVEMENT IN AMERICA.
THOUGH NOT SOLD
IN ANY MAJOR BOOKSTORES,
HIS BOOKS "DUMP TRUCK",
"NIGGER STAIN",
"I SMELL NIGGER"
AND "NIGGER BOOK"
HAVE SOLD OVER 600,000 COPIES
COMBINED.
DESPITE HIS POPULARITY,
VERY FEW HAVE EVER SEEN HIM
DUE TO HIS RECLUSIVENESS.
BUT IN AN EFFORT TO BRING
HIS MESSAGE TO A WIDER AUDIENCE,
HE AGREED TO GIVE HIS FIRST
PUBLIC INTERVIEW EVER...
TO "FRONTLINE".
BUT, GETTING TO MR. BIGSBY
WAS AN ODYSSEY IN ITSELF,
RIDDLED WITH
BACK-COUNTRY HOLLOWS,
SHIFTY GO-BETWEENS
AND PALPABLE DANGER.
EXCUSE ME.
NOT SURE WE'RE IN
THE RIGHT PLACE.
WE'RE LOOKING
FOR CLAYTON BIGSBY.
WELL, LOOK NO FURTHER, FELLA,
YOU FOUND HIM.
UH, CLAYTON BIGSBY,
THE AUTHOR ?
WHAT, YOU DON'T THINK
I CAN WRITE THEM BOOKS ?
JUST 'CAUSE I'M BLIND
DON'T MEAN I'M DUMB.
( host )
HOW COULD THIS
HAVE HAPPENED ?
A BLACK
WHITE SUPREMACIST ?
OUR SEARCH FOR ANSWERS
LED US HERE,
TO THE "WEXLER
HOME FOR THE BLIND",
WHERE MR. BIGSBY SPENT THE FIRST
19 YEARS OF HIS LIFE.
BRIDGETT WEXLER
IS THE HOME'S HEADMISTRESS.
WELL, HE WAS THE ONLY NIGRA
WE'D EVER HAD AROUND HERE,
SO WE FIGURED WE'D MAKE IT
EASIER ON CLAYTON
BY JUST TELLING HIM
AND ALL THE OTHER BLIND KIDS
THAT HE WAS WHITE.
AND HE NEVER
QUESTIONED IT ?
WHY WOULD HE ?
YOU'VE WRITTEN
FOUR BOOKS NOW ?
I'VE WRITTEN SIX BOOKS,
THEY'VE PUBLISHED FOUR.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY
IS THE OVERALL MESSAGE
OF YOUR BOOKS ?
SIR, MY MESSAGE IS SIMPLE.
NIGGERS, JEWS, HOMOSEXUALS,
MEXICANS, ARABS,
AND ALL KINDS OF
DIFFERENT CHINKS STINK,
AND I HATE THEM !
I NOTICED YOU REFERRED TO N--
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
WHAT EXACTLY
IS YOUR PROBLEM ?
HOW MUCH TIME
YOU GOT, BUDDY ?
WHERE WOULD I START ?
WELL, FIRST OF ALL,
THEY'RE LAZY,
GOOD-FOR-NOTHING TRICKSTERS,
CRACK-SMOKING SWINDLERS,
BIG-BUTT HAVIN',
WIDE NOSE BREATHIN'
ALL THE WHITE MAN'S AIR.
THEY EAT UP ALL THE CHICKEN,
THEY THINK THEY'RE
THE BEST DANCERS,
AND THEY STINK !
DID I MENTION
THAT BEFORE ?
YES, I BELIEVE YOU DID, SIR.
MATTER OF FACT,
MY FRIEND JASPER TOLD ME
ONE OF THEM COONS
CAME BY HIS HOUSE
TO PICK HIS SISTER UP
FOR A DATE.
HE SAID, "LOOK HERE, NIGGER,
THAT THERE'S MY GIRL.
ANYONE HAVE SEX WITH MY
SISTER, IT'S GONNA BE ME !"
YOU'VE NEVER LEFT
THIS PROPERTY,
HAVE YOU, MR. BIGSBY ?
NO, SIR,
NOT IN MANY YEARS.
WHAT IF I WERE TO TELL YOU
THAT YOU ARE
AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN ?
SIR !
LISTEN, I'M GONNA
MAKE THIS CLEAR.
I AM IN NO WAY,
SHAPE, OR FORM
INVOLVED IN ANY NIGGERDOM,
YOU UNDERSTAND ?!
YES, SIR, BUT--
BUT NOTHING !
NOW, IF YOU'LL EXCUSE ME,
I HAVE A BOOK SIGNING
TO GO TO.
WHY DON'T YOU BRING
YOUR MEDIA CAMERAS OVER THERE
IF YOU WANNA SEE
SOME REAL TRUTH ?!
PRUDENCE !
PRUDENCE, HAVE JASPER
LOAD THE TRUCK !